look at the series on your screen
2 6 10 and so on up to 26 30.
what will be the sum of all these
numbers put together can you tell me the
answer quickly
let's see to find the sum of all these
numbers we use a workaround technique
we know the formula for average its sum
of numbers divided by the number of
numbers
this way we get the formula of the sum
average multiplied by the number of
numbers
and we know the formula to find the
average and the number of numbers
average is first term plus the last term
divided by 2 which we get as 16
number of numbers is last term minus
first term divided by the difference
plus 1.
by solving this we get the answer as 8.
the sum is 16 times 8 which is 128
so we quickly found the value of the sum
using two formulas
using the same concept can you tell us
the answer to the sum of the series
don't forget to share this video with
your friends and family
you